okay today I'm going to talk to you
about sign APS's now sign apses are
involved where you have two neurons and
we're sending a signal from one neuron
to a second neural rod so just as a
recap a neuron is exactly the same as a
nerve cell they mean the same thing and
all it is is a type of cell which can
carry electrical impulses around the
body so how do they work because the
whole idea is we have an electrical
signal which travels down the first
neuron and what we're trying to do is to
get an electrical signal to travel down
the second neuron so electrical signals
are the reason why neuronal signals or
neuronal impulses are so fast now in
this neuron here what we have is we have
these little kind of things called
vesicles and they contain these things
that transmit the signal
which are called neurotransmitters so
when the electrical signal gets to the
end of this neuron it causes these
vesicles to release their
neurotransmitters into this gap here and
it's this gap here that's what a synapse
is a synapse is the gap between two
neurons so as you can see these little
chemicals here that have been released
by this neuron are called
neurotransmitters neuro because it's to
do with neurons transmitter because they
transmit a signal from this neuron to
this neuron so these little
neurotransmitters they diffuse they
travel across by diffusing across this
synapse and when they do they can bind
to receptors on this other sign-ups I'm
sorry on this other neuron the synapse
is the gap this is a neuron so the
neurotransmitter can bind to this
receptor and if we have enough of
these neurotransmitters then we're going
to get an electric signal electrical
signal which will travel down this
neuron as well so that's all there is to
it really
remember this is happening all the time
you have millions and millions of
neurons in your brain and you have
throughout your body having neurons as
well it's an electrical signal because
there's neurotransmitters to be released
into the synapse they diffuse across and
attach to a receptor bind to a receptor
and if there's enough it will cause an
electrical signal in this second neuron
and that's all there is the sign up says
thank you